hey guys i don't want to make this
overly dramatic like someone died or
anything like that but i do have
terrible news um
look i'm just gonna own it all right we
messed up and we do not have the video
for prof uh we did everything we could
i'm sure you're gonna give me your
comments about backups and how all that
works and we know but sometimes uh [ __ ]
happens and unfortunately
for this episode it did i'm i know
you're bummed you i can't tell you how
bummed i am all right not just this is
the first time in 10 years this has ever
happened to me
um
and i'm i'm sorry for
uh
prof i feel like i wasted his time and
we still have the audio so we're gonna
put something up you're still gonna be
able to listen to this episode um and
hear what he has to say and i promise
we're gonna have uh an episode too
um and i already told prof i called him
like a man and he was super cool about
it very understanding i know he's bummed
i can't tell you how bummed i am so i'm
sorry prof
uh mike cody your whole crew for coming
here
um and then we botched this and uh we've
been promoting it i know this is a big
cross promo for all of us and we got a
lot of
fans that in common
uh
and mostly i'm sorry to you guys i mean
it is killing me to sit here and do this
right now i'm sorry to you guys uh
but i mean
we just honeydew prof y'all i wish this
was a joke we just honeydew prof and i
can't say
how sorry i am i genuinely feel
embarrassed ashamed just disgusted i'm
sorry uh we will figure it out and fix
it
and make it right i promise you that but
you know we highlight the low lights i
had to tell y'all i'm highlighting the
low light to losing the video for prof
guys so please give it a listen
check it out throw it some love i
apologize sincerely it's late as [ __ ]
here at the studio i don't even want to
wake up to the comments tomorrow so uh
hey we get what we get um i love you all
i appreciate you all and again i'm sorry
hey guys just want to let you know all
merch is restocked we've got the night
pants we got the night pants nation
joggers hoodies keys night shorts all of
it
is back in stock head over to the
honeydew merch store and get your
honeydew gear today
[Music]
[Applause]
this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by upstart liquid iv ritual and
magic spoon more on that later let's get
into the do the honeydew with ryan
zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all social
media i want to tell you about tour
dates september 16th through the 18th
i'm in uh phoenix at the house of comedy
uh september 30th to october 2nd i'm in
helium indy i'm doing vegas with segura
october 8th and 9th headline in the bray
improv on october 28th all right more
dates coming go to ryansickler.com for
all tour dates sign up to the email list
you'll be on the early side of knowing
things all right the honeydew podcast is
the website for the show and make sure
you subscribe to the youtube it means
nothing to you to hit subscribe means
everything to us all right it's free it
doesn't even hurt you to do it subscribe
all right patreon
i'm telling you right now that
that show is so damn wild if you're not
subscribed now it's five bucks a month
it's the honeydew with y'all where i'm
highlighting the lowlights with y'all
okay and you know the crazy [ __ ] we're
hearing out there if you sign up for a
year you get a month free and you also
get the honeydew a day early ad free at
no additional cost all right you get the
whole back catalog all that [ __ ] and
ringtones of my laugh are available
again don't know why the [ __ ] y'all been
asking me for that but i did it it's out
there so now you better use it go to uh
go to my website and you can find info
there it's available on itunes
everywhere you get ringtones ringtones
of my laugh are out there and uh
honeydew athletes keep sending them in
i'm looking for everybody out there
that's different i want different i
don't want but i want good okay you got
to be good you can't just be ah you know
i [ __ ] play frisbee golf and i came
in last no i want the guy that's hole in
one in frisbee golf all right that's
what we want over here you all know we
do we highlight the low lights these are
the stories behind the storytellers i
can't
tell you how excited i am to have
today's guest here first time on the
honeydew ladies and gentlemen please
welcome prof welcome to the honeydew
prof
how exciting is this
um
i just want to talk about your ringtone
dude you mentioned you mentioned you're
like oh all this business and the behind
the scenes stuff and you're like yeah
then we're going to talk about the
ringtones and then you said the ringtone
of my laugh and then that's just kind of
all i want to talk about but we can
that's incredible i listen i've been
podcasting for like 10 years and for 10
years people been saying that i i don't
i don't use ringtone do you use
ringtones hold on a second
not just some terrible [ __ ] news
who's got kids oh man
they keep calling perfect you just
[ __ ] stalk and survive with my laugh
what's my stalker calling again like
it's like a dollar twenty nine on i dude
y'all uh people been asking it for so
long and finally i just hit my label up
thank you dom at uh blind medicine and i
was like man people want this can you
help me and he figured it out and did it
and
there they are they're out there i'm
gonna do it i'm gonna do it please i
would love it
um so before we get into everything
you'd like to talk about man plug
everything you got going
no
[Music]
you really don't want to plug anything
nah you gotta plug something huh all
right you're the first guest that's
official this is my twitter this is my
like you know
that's where you want to find let me try
out first if you like this interview and
you like all this stupid [ __ ] i say then
figure it out you know
all right fair enough yeah i do things
it's out there all right so i wanted to
get into your life story because i know
you rap i know you're a minneapolis guy
but you didn't come up easy this is why
you're on the [ __ ] show so stop start
just go from birth well yeah so uh
my manager was super hyped he's like oh
this is this is a direct hit for you
this this this podcast you know ryan
sickler the honeydew he's like look into
it and i looked and it was like we're
highlighting the low lights i'm like oh
yeah this is a direct hit for me
yeah this is perfect you know for my
[ __ ] up life we were talking about how
we wrote your [ __ ] trauma and a list
that it just if you're hearing my trauma
in the list
back to back like without any of the
good things it's like oh [ __ ] how am i
alive right without any of the good [ __ ]
how did i get here yeah you also realize
that most of life is is bad it's the the
highlights are there's highlights you
guys will get those that's what you get
it gets me through see what happens next
you know what i mean i like to keep
working at things and make things
and see what happens next you know so
i was born in minneapolis
uh in powderhorn which was like a super
super hood place in the in the 80s and
90s really high murder rate um
to a mom and a dad uh you know and they
married
so like right off the bat i was a
mistake with the family that was already
separated you know what i mean so oh so
your parents have been together and
split it was my dad's one last [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying like they were
already split up they hated each other
yeah like so there was three girls
christy charity sarah and then and then
it was like over and then my dad a
little you know some pillow talk
whispered a couple more sweetener things
and then pow
it was me so i'm happy my mom didn't
abort me
so that was cool so you're the youngest
of four then yeah but then there's some
mixed blended family [ __ ] and lots of
girls in my family oh really yeah um and
yeah that'll get complicated but um so i
was born yeah and powderhorn came up in
pothorn
parents separated like right away like
my first memories were uh like i asked
my mom the other day i'm like well
i have a memory and i that's just i've
had in my head of like
milk everywhere you holding me we are
both wet and then i'm like looking off a
porch
and like
my papa we call him papa but like dad's
getting arrested or something she was
like
oh my god she's like you were two you
were two years old no way yeah that's
that's that oh [ __ ] photos stuck in your
head when i was two she was like you
were legit two years old and that's a
real memory and what did she tell you
happened they got into a fight um
she threw milk at him or something like
her you know baby bottle or something
and it was all over and he was getting
arrested and putting shoved into a cop
car that was my first memory and uh
jesus that's the first memory yeah yeah
you're perfect for this show yeah i know
all right you know i'm like i'm i'm
nervous sitting here right now because
i'm like oh god like i got some juicy
[ __ ] for you man this could be a
five-hour podcast
um
yeah so uh then they separated and he
you know turns out later
much later i learned he was just totally
[ __ ] up he was he was mentally
unstable he was bipolar
you know super abusive did they know
that back then or is that when they're
finding this out no he didn't we didn't
know that he was so smart he was so
smart diagnosed like that back then but
he was so charismatic yeah if he was on
a high cycle you know on some uh [ __ ]
up [ __ ] and said he would just he would
control the room he was a preacher you
know i mean people [ __ ] loved him and
then he'd come home and [ __ ] whip my
ass you know what i mean like oh really
yeah he was he was so charismatic he was
so intelligent
super tortured
man you know
so
uh i don't know where to go when your
parents split do you live with mom do
you get to see dad do you bounce back
and forth i live with mom i live with
mom um and she she's like the best
person i've ever met and anybody meets
her they're like oh my god without her
i'd be in jail
dead i'm sure you hear this people say
that a lot but after some of the stories
you might hear you'd be like oh you
without her i would be [ __ ] up
so you know um i stayed with her
you know and there's like stories of
like i thought
my childhood was amazing you know and i
i remember having like this big teddy
bear for a bed
being like i have a you know my bed is a
gigantic teddy bear but like then the
story comes out that it was just a big
like fair toy that they found on the
back on the highway
you know that's what i'm sleeping on you
know what i mean
so a fair affair yeah like a left like
just [ __ ] on the sidewalk some
garbage
pick up some garbage like well there
goes that [ __ ] and i slept on
that you know i threw 97 miles an hour
god damn it
that's
yeah uh so
uh but then you know my mom was like she
she wanted a father in my life because
he was a good disciplinarian
hey but um when he was on he was he was
a great person a lot of the times but
the thing was it was wow and then it was
be someone completely different but i
have a lot of really good memories with
them really good at me what did your mom
do
a teacher she was a teacher teacher yeah
we were in section 8 poverty like it was
crazy she was a single mother with four
kids
um you can't do this no more so i don't
know
whatever
single mother four kids uh section eight
uh on welfare went to a community
college got a degree became a teacher
supported all of us on that bought a
house like right yeah no millennials can
do that kind of [ __ ] teachers i say this
all the time when we grew up teachers
had homes
no there wasn't a teacher i had teachers
live in an apartment yeah that's so
[ __ ] up that that
they can't buy houses anymore you're
right when i grew up teachers weren't
homeless yeah you know it was it was a
great time
i think they should let them live at the
school you know what the [ __ ] live work
yeah or pay them a decent wage
okay so she brings so she brought my dad
in he won half custody and then i was
just you know back and forth one week on
one week off living in a suitcase for 15
years
yeah and what was it like living at
dad's it was a [ __ ] he let me swear
super uh uh
real boy tomboy [ __ ] you know f fighting
like he would you know with all my
sisters when a suitor would come my
sisters were older than me and when
anybody try to date my sister suitor
that's such a that's so your own
suitor
when when a boy tried to [ __ ] my sister
uh
a guy came around
he would throw [ __ ] boxing gloves on
and in the backyard just in the hood and
potterhorn he'd be like there you go
buddy and he'd be like hold on hold on
i come to date your sister before i'm
allowed to take her out i got to fight
your dad
man i got a new thing i'm doing
my room you watch this my room i'll go
right up to my bedroom flip
i'd flip open the blinds and i would
just watch my dad beat the [ __ ] out of
like teenage boys underage kids
yeah he's abusing him having a backyard
yeah [ __ ] look [ __ ] i got three
girls let me beat one more yeah so no he
the so the boys would have anybody ever
really nervous
oh yeah yeah i ever catch so it was a
crazy uh
psychology experiment right he'd be like
he could figure out anything he wanted
to about these kids so he'd be they'd be
warm up the boys would be giggling
then my possibility
just a jab just just right to the head
and they'd be like what and he'd be like
he'd be like guys that's a joke huh
he'd hit him a couple times and then
he'd wait see how they react what kind
of person they are
i love it though it's crazy as [ __ ] but
i do love psychology [ __ ] nuts
yeah yeah holy so then yeah a couple
times if they'd hit him then it would
open my dad up for some a real gut shot
or something to the stomach or something
yeah so it was it was like i'm not gonna
[ __ ] with this kid yeah yeah he was
you're the one you could take yeah uh
and then he would decide you know after
if they were cool and deserve the
respect or whatever you know and then
they could date his daughters
jesus what did what was it like for you
to bring girls around him
uh
he burned my house down before right
so i i don't think i really brought
girls around him really i wasn't talking
to him at that point so what do you what
happened uh i was 15 and um
we got knew like i was getting older
yeah and i was figuring out like oh this
[ __ ] isn't normal
mean
i wasn't getting stronger i don't know
that didn't happen until i was like that
never happened
i was like man that doesn't make any
sense i don't even remember what we were
arguing about but there was this huge
fight when i was 15 i was like i get it
now [ __ ] you man like this is and he
wasn't diagnosed no one knew he was you
know only after he died did we like it
this these secrets come up like addicted
to opiates and like
bipolar and you know i don't know if
he's officially diagnosed or undiagnosed
or whatever you know
but um
yeah he was crazy like we we would uh
go to mcdonald one trip up to mcdonald's
the whole family after we would work
he'd take us to workouts at the ymca and
then we'd go to mcdonald's afterwards
and just eat a bunch of junk food and
just [ __ ] it was the 90s you know my
mother used to take us to mcdonald's
and then i mean we would she'd be like
get your food we'd eat it and she'd be
like i'm dropping you off at soccer
practice i'm like we just ate [ __ ]
trash people were dumb we just took
things for granted we weren't like
what's in this yeah whatever but wait
you jumped over you said he burned your
house down we can't just we can't just
jump over it oh we'll get there but i'm
sure this is of some psychology but i
don't want to make sure we see some
psychology before
so we're going to uh uh mcdonald's after
a workout and he
he sees a big
suv filled with uh bloods
throw some trash
and then they drove out so what he this
is the type of dude he goes you know
what he's with his family all his kids
you know white dude
[ __ ] he goes go inside order this
food you know don't you know and then he
just tells us all to go in there or the
food so i'm like all right whatever and
i'm in there ordering food and he's got
this like starter jacket that's like
reflective it's like nighttime now
i'm ordering my food and then like i see
this jacket just moving around like
like faster than a human could move
around like that's all i see i just see
this jacket just being tossed around i'm
like
no
no no and i keep on ordering for like
another 30 seconds and i was like no i
gotta look back i can look back again
and he's getting he's getting his
[ __ ] ass kicked and i'm going to my
my stepmom i'm like hey look at this and
he's just he just decides to fight you
know like
uh
eight to ten like [ __ ] cambodian
bloods like because they delivered you
know what i'm saying and he's
just he's in this you either pick the
trash up or you shut the [ __ ] well he
told him he said pick that [ __ ] [ __ ]
up you know and then they're like what
you know like they all get out the car
and he's like pick that [ __ ] up you know
what i mean like and he's he he was a
big dude you know like i'm six one he
was probably six two six three and like
he was it was he was fighting like eight
dudes and he was he was so [ __ ] up
lumped up quasimodo [ __ ] and
you know and then he came back uh and
like the cops were there and i remember
him sitting in the mcdonald's table like
and i was just right across from him and
he was like that's what we do you know
he's like yeah and he he was [ __ ] up
his face looked different
and i remember being like
oh
yo from then on i was like i'm a fighter
i'm a fighter that's that's my blood so
yeah
oh so that's just some psychology of
this man that's what we do yeah and so
yeah i got into a lot of fights when he
was after he died and i was just getting
drunk and battling and rapping and
[ __ ] on the streets i was just
fighting everybody
you know
so psychology the man
boom fast forward a little bit later and
he's you know he's in the basement
lighting lighting the fire to the house
now is this his house or your mom's
place this is his house now okay my mom
moved out okay um found you know married
again
and i don't remember what we were
arguing about but you know i remember
being like [ __ ] you and he was
devil-faced i knew what i knew i knew
that switch it was serious like we were
we had a circular dinner table and we
were moving around that thing you know
what i mean
so
um and then i left without anything
[ __ ] you he he was so brilliant every
argument he won and he would shape
people's thoughts you know and this is
the first time i was like that's not
going to happen anymore
you know when i was his his son he
always wanted a son it was all about
that masculinity that testosterone so
like
he he basically manifest destined me you
know what i mean so like
um
i was really important to him
and the control was really important for
him can i ask you this like during the
time you said he was abusive when he was
with your mom did he continue to be
abusive when you would go to his place
for the week at a time yeah he's still
physically abusive as well he uh you
know talking back to my sisters and
everything um he was like mentally
abusive to them and he would throw he
would do things like
just flip over [ __ ] you know an
argument if you didn't win he would just
but he never hit them he never hit them
uh and he hit me
um
and they didn't know that i was like i
never told you they really never did it
in front of them either no there was one
time i swear my sisters were around and
he [ __ ] licked me up and he threw me
down the stairs you know what i mean
jeez and i swear he they were there i
don't remember which sister it was a lot
of my a lot of my memories are really
foggy over these events in the past
um and so the burning down the house one
is just is the same i don't remember
everything about it but
i remember i was like nope argument
ain't gonna happen you're not gonna
shape my [ __ ] and i left
cooled off
um went to a neighborhood
uh girlfriend's house and uh hung out
there for an hour or two
had had to come home for dinner or
something or whatever and uh call home
landlines
busy
call home landlines
busy
call home landline busy all right well
can you just drop me back off you know
and so to drop me back off in the
neighborhood you know writing powerhorn
right in the hood 32nd 16th boom you
know
and there's just
[ __ ] the whole you can't even get two
blocks to it there's seven or eight fire
uh trucks police cars and everything
and do you think right away it's your
[ __ ] no no no i'm like oh [ __ ] yeah here
it goes again who's dead
you know that's what it is like in the
hood i'm like oh dope you know like when
i was a kid i didn't know how to you
know like i i took pride in that [ __ ]
because it made me tough like
[ __ ] i saw you know like we're going to
talk some [ __ ] today again
like so i'm thinking oh wow this is
crazy i'm like just drop me off here so
like uh you know the my girlfriend's dad
just he was like okay you know
took a left or whatever and then i'm
like crazy duck under the lines and then
i'm like crazy this is real close you
know running up more and more
and then
bro
like i i returned and the house was on
fire on fire like it was on fire
and it was
like a [ __ ] movie
uh
i was
screaming and um
i ran right all these fire they were the
firemen weren't paying attention nothing
i just went right in my front lawn
hey
and they're just running around me no
one's like picking me up or moving me it
was the most dramatic [ __ ] i'm at my
knees like no
like seriously screaming right in front
like
10 feet away from this
fire fire's coming out of the [ __ ]
windows
platoon [ __ ]
yeah
yeah yeah how could i be freaking out
like are your sisters in there is your
dad in there i'm alone i don't know
where anybody is i don't know what the
[ __ ] happened and they could be in there
you don't know i don't know yeah we lost
like a dog and iguana like some pets and
[ __ ] burned
um but so no one was in there
family
no family was hurt okay
um so what happened then my sister
arrives i don't know where she was at
and then she's like you know i was like
no but then a tough boy like damn you
know what's going on and she was just
she hugged me broke down cried like
crazy screaming crying for
you know the whole time and i was like
oh yeah this is serious and then in the
back of my mind i was like
i don't know what happened you did huh
then that's when you thought it like he
did this yeah where's he at
oh he's gone
oh the car is gone
he's not around
yeah
so we knew that and then you know
i went on some trip
like the day after or something like
that was scheduled you know like
um and we knew we just lived in a a
hotel for a while
now did he do you think he did it for
insurance or do you think he just did it
no no no no he was no he did it because
of me just pissed off pissed off i mean
i don't i don't take i don't take i
don't take responsibility for it but
sure you should yeah you didn't do it
because it's not because of me you know
i don't care what argument you have
burning someone's home your own home
your own home that's where i live too
you know like man hey can't control his
boy anymore you know it was kind of like
that son eat father father eat sun [ __ ]
you know
like someone was someone's killing
someone and it was just like that so
that shapes a lot of my [ __ ] my
language you know like
you know
i say a lot of rough [ __ ] just because
it [ __ ] feels good you know
so that happened
and then you know he escaped and was
like on the run for a while [ __ ] they
found him
with his wrist he was a nurse so he knew
how to switch his worse he was a nurse
he was a nurse he was a preacher he was
a [ __ ] yeah
he like studied lots of [ __ ] he was
[ __ ] brilliant and um so but yeah he
knew how to slit his wrist they found
him in [ __ ] in a hotel in duluth with
like blood on the ceiling in a tub
barely saved him
and then so like for that summer you
know we figured out he came back he's
alive and he you know he wore that
classic [ __ ] bandages around his
wrists all summer long because it was
that deep [ __ ] i don't know how he
didn't die
um
and then the next four years are super
fuzzy
i was just doing my thing and like do
you remember ever having a conversation
with him about why he burned the house
down this is the biggest
open wound of my entire life
never happened i didn't talk to him for
a long time
and he [ __ ] decided to die
before i could resolve anything so i
want to say 15 you said was how old you
are when the house 15 is one of the
house one on fire i died when i was like
20 or something so you only had a five
year window that you don't know you have
obviously mm-hmm and you never got to
have that conversation of why you burned
that that is worse than anything
there's no resolution uh and that's why
like i use rap as like i figured it out
you know
[ __ ] some [ __ ] up [ __ ] happened to
me in 2020 and i'm like thinking about
my past
trying to figure out why i am why i am
and like i use rap to take control back
from my dead father
i love it that's about what it is i mean
it's what i do i use humor to combat the
abuse from my mother and everything i've
dealt with
humor man yeah i got in trouble for
humor and some tweets
and um but i'm like that's that's what
that's
what gives me resolution and and control
over those things if i can joke about
bro that's not a problem to me no more
right you know yeah and that's why i
[ __ ] fall away from it exactly but
like i say all the time too like
healthy people look you need to sit in
your own [ __ ] you need to sit there for
a little bit you need to look around you
need to smell it you need to feel it you
need to know what that's like and then
you need to decide am i going to stay
here or am i going to get the [ __ ] up
out of here and move forward that's it
if someone can suff deprecate and humor
when
boom if i meet someone and they [ __ ]
insult themselves with humor i'm like
right away wide open door man what's
your number like that that takes that's
just a sign of so many good well you all
should have showed up at the comedy
store saturday night when you had
tickets that's where i was i'll
self-deprecate myself all night on stage
that was wild just to let everybody know
we had tickets to his show we didn't
even know you were performing they don't
they don't advertise it right
you got to go on their social media and
and look for it but they promoted we
missed out we usually what they do is
put the lineups up you know what i mean
and then you just got to look for the
name [ __ ] if we would have known we
would have
canceled what we were doing
we missed that show but i love that you
you take that and harness it and use it
that you know that power that way let's
take a quick break and tell you about
our first sponsor upstart if you are
carrying a credit balance month after
month it can feel like you're in a
never-ending cycle of debt upstart can
help you make that final payment so you
can get ahead upstart is the fast and
easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan all online whether it's
paying off credit cards consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses over half a million people have
used upstart to get one fixed monthly
payment i say it all the time you guys
are using upstart you like upstart i
wish i had something like this you know
i was always rotating high interest
credit card balances and trying to do
what i could and you end up paying
thousands and thousands of more dollars
than you really need to pay
so upstart knows you're more than just
your credit score and it's expanding
access to affordable credit unlike other
lenders upstart considers your income
and your current employment to find you
a smarter rate for your loan with a five
minute online rate check you can see
your rate up front for loans between a
thousand to fifty thousand dollars and
you can even receive funds as fast as
one business day after accepting your
loan here's what you gotta do all right
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com honeydew that's upstart.com
honeydew don't forget to use the url to
let them know i sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
your income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com honeydew
our next sponsor is liquid iv the hot
summer months are here and we need to be
proactive to keep our body fueled up and
hydrated all right i love liquid iv you
know we've been talking about it from
the pandemic till now a summer to
drinking hangovers whatever it is it
works stay hydrated take care of
yourself out there
makes your skin look good makes you feel
good and liquid iv is the truth i'm
telling you all right liquid iv hydrates
faster and more efficiently than water
alone it contains five essential
vitamins more vitamin c than an orange
and as much potassium as a banana it's
healthier than sugary sports drinks
there are no artificial flavors or
preservatives and there's less sugar
than an apple it's made with clean
ingredients non-gmo vegan and free of
gluten dairy and soy and what makes
liquid iv so effective is the cellular
transport technology that ctt y'all the
optimal ratio of glucose sodium and
potassium delivers water and nutrients
into the bloodstream it's the perfect
balance to help you hydrate more quickly
and effectively than water alone one
stick of liquid iv in a 16 ounce of
water hydrates faster and more
efficiently than water alone liquid ivy
is on a mission to change the world
liquid iv has donated over 11 million
servings globally here's what you got to
do grab your liquid iv in bulk
nationwide at costco or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
code honeydew at checkout we all use it
here everybody here is using it the kids
in the the outreach through the arts
programs are using it they all love it
that's 25 off of anything you order when
you get better hydration today using
promo code honeydew at liquid iv.com
now let's get back to the do um
i got a lot of things i want to ask you
what other things did you want to talk
to your dad about that that you didn't
get to or what are you looking back on
it now okay because you haven't said
this yet but you're a father now mm-hmm
you had a baby you had a daughter no no
no but i had a baby you had a baby well
now everybody knows it's a son
yeah no not a dollar i just had a baby i
thought you said my girl but you meant
your girl had yeah my girl had a baby
gotcha so you have a son yeah and
not a year yet or coming up he's a year
a year he was born right when the entire
world shut down in kovalev
did that scare the [ __ ] out of you that
was very very scary everybody in the
hospital during all that yeah like uh
everybody was scared when coveted and
everything locked up but like we were in
a hospital and then they kicked
everybody out
then my baby had some crazy [ __ ] where
you had to stay in the icu for seven
days
so we were sleeping and we were sleeping
on the floor in the hospital you know
waking up every three hours trying to
feed him you know all that kind of crazy
[ __ ] and uh every time we would go
walk down to see
my guy my little dude in the icu
the
everything changed like it was like a
weird story of like
i was waiting on this bad but like
more things happening every time we go
downstairs there's another [ __ ]
police officer more police officers then
there's tape then there's ropes then
there's like so every time we went up
and down i'm like oh [ __ ] so like day
three i was like this is some weird
militarized i'm like man no one knew
what the [ __ ] was going on this dude is
like
in tubes and [ __ ] up his nose and
[ __ ] getting pricked all the time i'm
like this is the craziest [ __ ] that's
going to happen to me in 2020
not even close
so yeah he turned out to be good um
so let's go back now you're a father
yeah i mean my father was everything to
me he died when i was 16 and i know when
i just sit there holding my daughter in
my arms
i mean it was this bittersweet moment
where i'm so happy to be a dad but i
don't have one i can't i have no library
of information to go to like how the
[ __ ] you do you had twins bro why didn't
you bounce in the 70s you know what i'm
saying like you were a real [ __ ] man
you're a twin how'd you do that yeah
fraternal twin but um
you know
boom boom and nothing and all these
moments and so i my daughter knows who
my father is and there was one night she
just started crying why are you crying
she's like i miss grandpa lefty and i
just started bawling i was like i do too
like what the [ __ ] are you you even met
him so i got pictures of him around the
house i make sure she knows who that
everyone is i know make sure she knows
where she comes from
uh anytime she falls and gets hurt i
make sure i tell her she's got baltimore
blood in her get the [ __ ] up you know
you ain't no posters those are santa
monica posters yeah first time i hear
you and you're like y'all
what is he from texas what the [ __ ] i
couldn't get it but yeah baltimore all
right yeah so yeah but
losing someone what are you dealing with
as a father right now and losing your
father you know you yeah
how's that affecting you i mean the
other day i was like
man as as an adult in my 20s i was
looking back i was like i wish i had
someone
like a role model man who could let me
know what i'm what's happening to me in
my 20s and like yes and then i went oh
that's a father i was like oh that's a
dad oh [ __ ] i wish i guess i wish i had
a dad
yes teach me about money and not just
how to spend it and save it you know
teach me about like consciousness i
don't know anything teach me about like
my anger and what and
drink and drugs and [ __ ] teach me about
like
how what happens with a job or like
those kind of things yeah you know
so
yeah the best thing my father did and
you didn't get this but
well maybe you did because you said he
was charismatic he worked he hustled he
gave me a lot but
yeah my my father was an example of how
to be so i didn't get those
conversations from 17 to 48
but my my father was an example of the
type of person and man to be and that
was enough yeah okay i got it okay
you know yeah i don't know what the [ __ ]
i don't know i i i get triggered it's
it's that's you know
and um
there's times like you said like when
your daughter says something like that
or you know when
you know if you get big big life events
boom that's just that just bloodline's
gone like that's such a like a
crazy bittersweet thing to like share
with other people too like i love like
hurt people who like can sympathize with
that and understand what that feels like
and it's just like a deeper meaning and
it's like for me it's just a crazy hole
that i think
a lot of anger comes from me you know
what i mean that i still kind of kind of
got to deal with you know because he did
all he did was fight northward oh he
left
he never
i wish i could just approach him as a
man and just be like you know also who i
am now i wish he could see who i am now
and sit down with him and but it'd be
interesting to see who he is now too you
know and i wonder too if being a
grandfather changes the man too
absolutely you know he was trying to
change like was my mother's a
a better grandmom than she was a mom to
you know i know that yeah well probably
in my 20s i would want to fight him
like if you if i were to bring him back
to life i would be like all right let's
fight you know i wouldn't even want to
talk and like now i'm like
maybe i'll just ask them some questions
and [ __ ] and like to see if forgiveness
is
something you know
yeah that's cause you're healing yeah
you don't want to fight all the time
plus you can't be you're not you look
like you're i swear to god you look like
your goddamn 27 to 30. you told me
you're 37
but you can't be you know that dude in
your 40s still fist fighting people yeah
only from self-defense yeah you know
last time i got in a fight it was in
st louis
and i jumped off stage and hit a fan in
the stomach
what did he do he took my microphone at
the [ __ ] climax of the show we had
this whole thing we're going back out
for the encore and i'm like yeah and i
hold the microphone over the crowd like
this on the stand and he just goes
and because then i need to do that and
grab the microphone for like some last
thing and he's like oh and he's all
drunk and he runs away and i'm and i
still got like i've been good but
sometimes it goes
in a clip i'm just like just run out
there and i'm just i'm like going across
put one in his stomach and take my
microphone back but it's cool
yeah so i don't know where we're headed
with this
a lot of anger and rage oh like what
yeah
all right so now all that's happening
with your dad and everything where's mom
um obviously your relationship's super
strong is she just that backbone for you
to go and talk to yeah always all the
time so she's always been there and um
well listen your mom's dealt with men in
her life it's not like she can't [ __ ]
give you some sound advice all men as
well you know
my mom was a gee she's like a cute
little tiny very beautiful like a blonde
woman but then i asked her questions
about stuff she said i ran away from a
house when i was 16 i hitchhiked to
california and one of them in a girl's
house i'm like wow you're
she's a hood [ __ ]
oh damn
you thought you thought
so um yeah i'm just did you ever ask
your mom what she saw on your dad and
what it was about him that got them
together originally no but i don't i
don't need to dude could win over
anybody yeah he was on if he wanted to
you know yeah he could win over anybody
anytime so i want to ask this question
when they found him near death did he
also get arrested for arson like did
they yeah he went to prison so he went
to prison so how did you visit him in
prison [ __ ] no i didn't talk to him for
like five years until he [ __ ] died
he was on a [ __ ]
stationary bike
at the ymca in minneapolis no the one he
would take you guys too it's at
mcdonald's that's [ __ ]
mcdonald's came back to get him got that
[ __ ] mcdonald
he tried to fight his way through it too
he's like oh no no it wasn't he was like
what the [ __ ] is this
i'm gonna all peddle this [ __ ] you're on
a stationary bike you ain't going
nowhere bro
you ain't walking a heart attack off bro
yeah yeah so he died there yeah in front
of like a bunch of yeah like yeah
and when all right so so fun that's
funny it is that's weird like i would
like to say like he died in a shootout
or something no he died on a stationary
bike at the white house at the ymca
south dale minneapolis in front a lot of
people yeah in front of people working
out with the headphones and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] that's terrifying if you're them to
see that go down yeah i'm not gonna i'm
i'm stopping workouts over this exercise
bikes ain't no good for you right yeah
yeah i'm done working out let's go to
mcdonald's
what do you continue as they've like
just take them out on a stretcher dead
look i'm gonna i'm gonna kill this
workout that is how life is that's how
life is your dad's going out gone and
everybody else is just pedaling on bikes
i remember we did the vegas comedy
festival like two years ago and we're
walking down the
street and someone literally on this
corner over here gets shot
right there well we're all there you
hear people scream everybody this
motherfucker's shot he's dead but
everybody's walking by with their
hurricanes just sipping their straws and
[ __ ] you know what i mean life doesn't
give a [ __ ] i like that about it though
like uh there's something about that you
know after a huge death or something
like that or something [ __ ] awful
there's something comforting the birds
don't give a [ __ ] the sun is gonna rise
and it's gonna be like tweeting to you
like i like to imagine myself when i'm
meditating i don't know how to meditate
but i like to have a cup of coffee in
the morning and then just like pull my
head about 300 feet in the air and just
look around at the trees and [ __ ] and
that's [ __ ]
they don't give a [ __ ] what happened
about anything i've never had that
thought i'm gonna try that that's what i
do every morning that is meditating then
you do know what it is i don't know what
it is but i like to float in the air and
just look at the city [ __ ] yeah i
usually sit up on a cloud you know
[Laughter]
um wait i want to go back to your dad
dying walk me through that day for you
who calls you how do you find out what
happens i was at i was in i was in an
apartment i was living with uh an
apartment with my sister in uptown
and i was like with my ex-girlfriend at
the time i don't know what the [ __ ] she
was coming to get something or something
and you know i'm just gonna get a phone
call from my sister
i had a heart attack
my ringtone coming in
well dad's dying all right
and then your sister's calling he's
having a heart attack all [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay that's crazy
and then
second call he's dead
you know and then i just sank to the
[ __ ] floor
what did that feel like legs gave out
um
no
platoon [ __ ] i'm in the front then i'm
in front of my house as it's burning
down
uh felt [ __ ] really weird like this
this is happening right now it's really
crazy that
of a lot of
familiar
familiar really weird tragic feeling
that's i've had a lot of it here it is
again like here it comes it's i can't
explain it it's like a
something's unreal
some twilight zone type [ __ ] but it's
deep and it hurts
and it's like fake it's not real and
it's that was going on and i'm oh this
is familiar familiar feeling
yeah
um
how did your mom react to that
do you remember i don't remember you
have you ever talked to your mom about
your dad passing
did she come to the funeral and stuff
like that or was it like was it that bad
where she wouldn't even do that she was
at the phoenix i think i don't know yeah
right uh-huh i've
i think i have a lot of really i think
uh losing memory over traumatic events
is real i think that's really happening
oh it definitely did i remember my dad's
i remember the viewing
way better than i remember the funeral i
don't remember the mass i remember the
ride to the cemetery i don't remember
what was said or who the [ __ ] talked
that over i remember throwing some dirt
on the [ __ ] and getting out of
there and that was it i remember like
walking my like everybody looking at me
like
you know
as i walk in with his [ __ ] casket or
whatever and then like sitting down and
being like everybody's looking at me i'm
a young dude and here's my dad
you know i remember i remember that and
you know i'm sure i had conversations
with my mom and [ __ ] but like bro i
don't remember i've toured the country
15 times over again every single [ __ ]
city so like my memory is [ __ ] i've
done so many things and so lived so fast
like i don't remember [ __ ]
so that's the end of the episode i guess
all right so i want to talk to you about
when you first realized you had this
gift in
uh rapping and how you sort of put your
energy and time into that it was a
[ __ ] survival technique you know like
i i i was living in powderhorn i was
getting my ass whooped all the time like
white kid in potterhorn in the 1990s was
you know it wasn't that easy you know
what i'm saying i would get people i'll
get
just you and your sisters yeah just my
family
there are three other ones yeah we all
live together no like i would love to go
down to the park like i want to go and
play and everything but then like the
football team
would just like jump me and take my
shoes and my clothes and stuff like this
like
it was the football they were like in in
their uniform and [ __ ] you know like
they weren't like trying to nonchalantly
do this [ __ ] like the football team did
it i don't know
uh
so it was like it was it was it was
[ __ ] it was
drastic dude it was bro it was like
i had to come to like i had to make a
decision
every time i [ __ ] stepped out there i
was getting hurt
and then
there was options for me though like
there was a couple people or else i
would hurt someone else that's only
where like
i'll be rolling with some this new crew
here's some knives and [ __ ] hey let's go
[ __ ] take these bikes and [ __ ] i'm
like oh this feels better
all right so i'm gonna rob this dude
with y'all
and take his bike and [ __ ] so that's
cool i'm like do i have to so if if i
step out this [ __ ] house
i need to
either someone's getting hurt i need to
[ __ ] stab somebody or or i need to be
the hardest [ __ ] out here to
prove myself over and over again or else
i can't come out the house
you know what i mean
and i was thinking i was thinking about
it like what the hell like am i just
gonna be like a video game nerd like i
wanna go outside like i wanna play
sports and [ __ ] you know i want to do
things i didn't want to stay in the
house
and it dawned on me i was like
i just gotta start clowning
[ __ ] make jokes and
wow stab them lyrically bro yeah and so
i you know i was just joking on people
started rapping and then i was like good
at it getting into battles who were your
influences
who were you listening to goody mob
yeah like a lot a lot of minneapolis rap
was doing like this emo [ __ ] and like
doing like very like backpack like uh
really conscious rap and [ __ ] and i was
like listening to like ludicrous and
[ __ ] goody mob and [ __ ]
you know a million a million
[ __ ] but more more like
southern rap actually okay yeah so then
when you start it was more the energy
that i was feeling i was i was mad it
was
it was dirty it was aggressive yeah you
know and i
that
that was my [ __ ]
you like trick daddy mm-hmm i love trick
that
trick daddy but i like them a long time
ago a long long time ago i wish my
manager was here i think i might have a
song with him see the trick daddy or um
someone else i don't have a song with
someone like that who's in dude spinning
around your hair's been like a
helicopter north carolina
is that trick daddy i don't know
i got some cool features look it up and
follow me uh [ __ ] profgompo at
twitter
[ __ ] 40 minutes
um
yeah i know you want to follow me now
dad was [ __ ] dead and i was just
[ __ ] angry
um and i loved art dude i was tagging i
was you know i was i was i was i did a
lot of crimes and
um you know went to jail you know got
caught you know it's the first time you
went to jail
for what
graffiti you got rested this story is
[ __ ] nuts yeah i was i was
i was
doing graffiti dude and then the police
came this was my first experience with
police in minneapolis
15 16. this is then this is after your
house after the yeah after the house
burned down but right your dad i'm not
talking to him
and um
dude
you know cop car pulls up we're running
we're hiding it's me and my dude and
we're hiding behind a uh
down the alley behind a garage and the
car i hear the cop coming they were
chasing us but he didn't he didn't know
we were there here's footsteps he's
talking he's saying
like
this dude's scary he's not like a poli
he's not like apprehending the suspect
that you know i'm like this was like i i
uh vandalized something and it was
property damage i was like this is like
he's gonna [ __ ] kill me he said that
and he started pissing he was i was on
this side of the wall what and he was on
this side of the wall he started pissing
right there and while he was saying how
he's going to [ __ ] kill me you see
his pistols this is like coming on me
like ah
it's coming on their own
my guy was right there and the piss was
going over my feet
and he saw it and he was like i ain't
getting pissed on and he just jumped up
boom jackrabbit wow just jumping over
fences boom lights go on and then the
[ __ ] chase is on then i'm like all
right i'm right behind you and there's
multiple squad cars or whatever and um
we're running as fast as we possibly can
and i'm i was fast as [ __ ] i was varsity
track if i wanted to freshman year i'm
skinny as hell i was dipping and this
dude was dipping too but
when you're running as fast as you can
one six-inch curb
does stuff
and he [ __ ] fell down
i adjusted and i looked back and he was
just
they just [ __ ]
[ __ ] him up [ __ ] him up
and then so i'm looking back i'm
terrified now i'm like these dudes will
[ __ ] kill me and then i run back to
the uh
[Music]
house we were all bombing out of we had
a crew and we were staying up at you
know it was 5 a.m or whatever and we'd
go out and just destroy lake street um
and there was we can't we went out in
teams like we were
thorough about our [ __ ] and then um
the other team wasn't there yet you know
and they didn't know what's happening
we're meeting back at the house the
other team that was out you know bombing
and then so i'm just hiding there and
then i then they they come back and i
get back and i'm like yo i'm trying to
wash my hands i'm like they [ __ ] they
got they got you made it they got back
there oh oh oh did i make it yeah
i'm like they got us i'm like
they're coming or whatever they whip the
[ __ ] out of him beat him beat him force
the confession where you staying at
right now no
yeah
and so
uh the brother one of the guys who was
with me or the brother of the guy
standing there another dude kind of
looks like me
police at the door and i'm at the
basement oh the police are here go down
and and i hear right above at the door
he goes
opens the door well
wow tidal wave whoop the [ __ ] out of him
come in the house flip them over flip
all the [ __ ] they destroyed the whole
house beat the [ __ ] out of him because
he kind of looked like me or something
it might be you it just might be oh i'm
hearing
disaster upstairs i'm like oh [ __ ] so
i'm
i'm going out the basement and then i go
out the side door run outside or light
goes on again oh [ __ ]
here we go again and then they chase me
again i'm in another foot chase and i i
take them to this train tracks over the
mississippi river that are falling apart
and that like it closed
um like the wood is like [ __ ] up and
i'm like and it's 300 feet above the
river deadly and i'm like i'm gonna go
run across that you know because they'll
they're gonna [ __ ] kill me yeah
minneapolis police bro there's some re
look
yeah so you know i knew this [ __ ] early
that it was like [ __ ] 12 you know the
minute especially in minneapolis so yeah
then i yeah that's one of the stories
then i walk all the way
from
saint paul minnesota all the way to
[ __ ] southwest minneapolis and like
um just getting my just
up up franklin hood ass uh street
just getting in fights with bums and
[ __ ] when did they get you
i turned myself in to to because they
took dude who looked like me all they
did yeah so i talked to my mom she's
like oh well i'll walk into jail with
you and i was like all right so you know
she she was by my side and we went
downtown and turned myself in they kept
him they did anyway
really letting him go
oh my gosh
all he did was answer the door
yeah was he was you know no
more
no he was doing other [ __ ] that night
too so but
uh
yeah and then i went i went to church
the next morning
did you yeah are you a church guy no
that day you were though huh well i just
wanted to like
you know if you murder someone the next
day you just stick to your schedule yeah
you know what i mean but yeah i wasn't i
mean
once i saw my dad who was a preacher
pastor like
when everybody over and everybody being
like oh you're the best like anybody who
acts holier than now
or preaches at anybody and says i gotta
fig like that they they got the angels
on their side
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our next sponsor ritual we deserve
to know what we're putting in our bodies
and why especially when it comes to
something we take every day rituals
clean vegan-friendly multivitamins
formulated with high quality nutrients
in bioavailable forms your body can
actually use i take it every day i've
been taking it every day for months stop
taking the the multivitamins that you
can get in the store started reading up
about them and i'm telling i say it all
time sawdust and all these other things
garbage in this stuff i get ritual it
comes to my mailbox i don't go anywhere
and i love it it's got a minty fresh
taste to it that i even though i still
can't really taste much can actually
taste all right ritual is the
multivitamin reimagined a multivitamin
should contain key nutrients and forms
your body can actually use to help fill
gaps in the diet no shady extras rituals
delayed release capsule design delivers
high quality nutrients including vitamin
d3 in just two daily pills all right
ritual is made traceable so you'll
always know what nutrients you're taking
and where they come from thanks to
rituals one of a kind visible supply
chain ritual makes healthy habits easy
your multivitamins are delivered to your
door every month with free shipping
always you can start snooze or cancel
your subscription anytime and if you
don't love ritual within your first
month they'll refund your first order
get key nutrients without the bs ritual
is offering my listeners 10 off during
your first three months visit ritual.com
honeydew to start your ritual today
our next sponsor is magic spoon growing
up cereal was one of the best parts of
being a kid but i had to give it up
because i realized it was full of sugar
and junk that you really just shouldn't
eat but not magic spoon it's got zero
grams of sugar 14 grams of protein and
only four net grams of carbs
in each serving it's also only 140
calories all right try magic spoons best
selling flavors in a four flavor variety
pack featuring cocoa fruity frosted and
peanut butter all right listen i've
tried all of them i'm not even lying to
you at all they taste just like the
cereals from your childhood and you
could take the cocoa and the peanut
butter throw them together you know what
i'm saying it tastes just like cereal
from your childhood but it's super
nutritious okay it tastes amazing and
it's honestly too good to be true it's
keto friendly it's gluten free it's
grain free it's soy free and it's low
carb all right i promise you i've tried
all four of them no bs go to
magicspoon.com honeydew to grab a
variety pack and try it today and be
sure to use the promo code
honeydewcheckout to get five dollars off
of any order and magic spoon listen to
this is so confident in their product
it's backed with a 100 happiness
guarantee so if you don't like it for
any reason they'll refund your money no
questions asked i'm telling you guys
i've tried all four of them and they're
good and i can taste some of these all
right but i can taste the sweet i know
what they taste like and everybody i'm
sharing them with ash just took the
frosted ones today everybody loves them
all right so that's magicspoon.com
honeydew use the code honeydew for five
dollars off or just click the link below
to save five dollars today now
let's get back to the do but you also
saw some you told me you saw some tragic
[ __ ] too is it you saw murders you
witnessed them
yeah
all of them there's a lot of shootings
in potterhorn and there's a lot of them
my favorite but were you poor
no not i mean i was i was part of like a
street gang for a while robbing people
for a while but not no no not the
cambodian bloods no it was all there was
no white gang like i needed to join a
black gang that's kind of scary yeah
so yeah i was doing scary [ __ ] for a
while but i was like let me just be the
comedian class clown [ __ ] you know i was
a [ __ ] clown in high school that's
what chappelle talks about is like if
you see a white guy rolling with a black
crew
you that's the scariest [ __ ]
because whatever he did the win over
that crew yeah is [ __ ] crazy i knew
that's what i had to do yeah that's why
i was like i'm not gonna be that guy
right no i'm not that dude
i didn't want to kill anybody i don't
want to kill anybody dude yeah
so uh your favorite favorite murderer
karen kilgare we'll [ __ ] do
let me tell you about my favorite murder
uh
my favorite one [ __ ] outrageous
south side
powderhorn [ __ ] i'm coming i'm on a
school bus
my sister's with me
we're getting dropped off it's like 3
p.m
and
we're you know riding up on my stop
bro
yeah
yeah and the bus driver is like
shh
comes to a stop
just opens up the door
we get up we were like we're getting off
here you know it was uh i mean it was it
was happening while we were pulling off
but like we got out
there's people just
there they were dying like the neighbors
yeah there was like three or four of
them drive by
holy [ __ ] bus driver
was like [ __ ] this just
stop
this so uh yeah so the neighbors were
out um
mr leah scholly
uh uh a neighbor of a kid
mother of a kid that i went to school
with she's like trying to save one she's
screaming
trying to perform this over here and
then you know they were running so one's
underneath the clothes lines and in the
backyard of another place one's just
right on the corner which is [ __ ]
real life blood everywhere you're you
know i just step right out into that
[ __ ]
you know that's your neighbor that's
your neighborhood that's my block
god damn
yeah
yeah so we stayed around and at this you
know at this age it was so stupid man i
asked you this is that was that your
first time seeing a dead body that that
time
uh
i don't remember i remember my first
dead body
i mean that's early in your life yeah
that's pretty good i think i think that
could be it yeah yeah and you're not
just seeing one it was three [ __ ] triple
homicide
they all got it
so we stayed there and at the time i
remember being like i wasn't i didn't i
didn't know the value of life and [ __ ]
i'm looking at movies and i'm trying to
be tough too in that neighborhood so i'm
like
i can't wait to brag to my friends that
i just saw three dudes die that's how i
was thinking back then like
you know i look back now i'm like
that [ __ ] me up you know if i saw that
now it'd be like
[ __ ] up yeah hell yeah three humans
really [ __ ] up in front of you yeah
but i was a child man i wasn't developed
and so i stood around there like i'm
gonna stay here i'm gonna take a step
back just watch it all and then when the
news comes they're gonna interview me
i'm here for the interview i'll be on tv
you know so i did that
and did you get the interview they
interviewed me they really did yeah
some white kid being like hey
me and my sister
let's just stick right here we don't
need to go home right now let's just
watch this get cleaned up and then
when the news crew gets here
let's get on tv damn dude
um yeah i mean
what else one night my house got shot
the [ __ ] up the front of my house oozy
or something
just we were just sitting in a house i
was upstairs in it wrong house i don't
know like oh it's not like this little
[ __ ]
white family was you know i was like
someone just shot up a house while i was
in it
like jesus 30 [ __ ] bullets
you know
yeah
what else have you seen
uh
you seen murders what else what other
kind
i haven't seen any well
i've seen some stabbings yeah yep street
fights and [ __ ] like that
um what's the craziest thing you've seen
in rap on the road out there
so i imagine your fans are quite
different from my fan look we have a lot
of the same fans which first of all blew
me away so i know you got good fans i
know you guys i know
they're good they are yeah but i bet
you've seen some [ __ ] out there my one
one of the craziest most [ __ ] up wild
moments i've ever had in rap where you
look around and you're like
look at this [ __ ] like it it was it was
a show um i was i was younger drinking
at the dinky towner it was a famous
little really shitty club that i was
rapping at 16 17 would let me drink i
was a [ __ ] man you know um
but this was probably
early 20s it was a we did a
halloween show
and bring your costumes so everybody's
dressed up to the tea there's a costume
competition with like a grand prize
and this is when you know everybody knew
my crew was fighting and [ __ ] and um
uh we did the show
and then my man roswell he like he does
he just started the fight somewhere i
don't remember how it started but it
turned into
just some
the show was over
bar closed we're in the streets
everybody's smoking drinking straight
west coast and and um
power just the best craziest fight start
pops off out of nowhere everybody's in
like grover costumes and like mammograms
and like one dude's dressed as like a
tennis player with like
and everybody's bombing everybody's
bombing people got rackets there was a
there was a dude who was dressed as a
football player just knocking
[ __ ] out and it was a it was it
was a
it was a it was like a [ __ ] irish
[ __ ] it was like uh
some of lines of like 20 people versus
20 people like marching at each other
and like there's one and you're up there
rapping while it's happening no this is
outside it's over i'm in it i'm in it
and you know um
there's just you look around and you're
like this person's dressed this dude
this dude is knocking this [ __ ]
out and he's got like titties and like
and like he's dressed in and [ __ ] you
know what i mean and and then there's
this one one moment when you know i'm
just
no one knows what's going on or why
anybody's getting fighting it's just
someone hit my friend now i gotta hit
you and then and then and then you don't
know remember one time i turn around and
i'm about to i hit this dude he's like
prof it's me like oh and i'm like oh
you're on our side or like yeah you
don't even know yeah and then and then
c's parted and then there's this
huge man looking at me i'm like six one
he's like
six seven and he's like yup
me and you and i'm like
okay
you know you're like i would rather like
sneak up and knocked out this guy or
whatever but it was just like just me
and him and i'm like i don't he's gonna
he's gonna he's gonna [ __ ] me up my
dog's like whatever i'm like walking at
him and then [ __ ] out of nowhere this
tennis player my homie [ __ ] jump
kicks him in the chest and he flies into
a car
and then i love him yeah yeah so that
was one of those one of my favorite
[ __ ] andre agassi coming out of
nowhere dropkicking
yeah and then my homie scotchie went to
his trunk and he gets his real sword
like this dude is like a sword who
carries a sword in there dude he does
he
he developed a reputation for this
[ __ ] sword in the neighborhood listen
i would say if you did that once you got
the reputation like this [ __ ]
might pull a sword all you do is one he
did that over and over there's a lot of
stories about how somebody gets to get
out of traffic and just pop the trunk
no [ __ ] sword bro like he's huge he's
huge
i don't know he was knocking out a lot
of people and it was swords lots of
blood in the streets and then we [ __ ]
won it was awesome and then like
everybody's like knocked out and we just
walked away it was
crazy but then one of my homies went
back to like trying to spit on him and
then they all like woke up and then they
just beat him up
i'm like why'd you go back
i was already like
let's go and then he was like he went
back and then they all woke up and beat
his ass but
um
i want to talk about you also obviously
we had our situation here with uh
the riots and everything and you lit you
lived what you said that was your block
where you lived right around the corner
from the epicenter of everything i was
there was you know uh i moved from that
house in the meantime so i i could tell
you i didn't want to say anything about
it but
it was there's only
there's a huge kind of um
saying anything about it no i'm out of
there i'm out of there there's this huge
commercial area my house is right on the
corner of it
and so
it was i lived right next to the third
precinct in minneapolis there's maybe
you know considering how
you know the blocks move around it and
there's ten houses closer to it and i'm
right there in the front yard so people
started looting and [ __ ]
i'm like the first residential block
and all the blocks started just filling
up with cars like you know the protests
were real and the people who were there
to do that were doing good work and then
they figured out all right this is the
complete pandemonium
complete pandemonium what else you want
to do
you are you a
bank robber
there's a bank right there now is the
time there's bank right across from my
house like
grab your dynamite let's rob this
[ __ ] bank you know so
everybody was doing everything so there
was a moment where it was like pretty
crazy so i had all my friends over we
were all strapped we're just in the
front yard drinking and it turns out you
know it was pretty obvious right away no
one was [ __ ] with residential [ __ ]
even if you know you were there for like
some [ __ ] [ __ ] no one was touching
houses same thing actually here now that
you say that it was all businesses and
[ __ ] up this boulevard and stuff yeah so
that was cool so we you know i'm just
[ __ ]
got a gun in my lap and i'm just
watching it with my neighbors drinking
beer and you know people are coming back
from target that they have just full
shopping carts full conveyor belt
you know double takes i'm just i'm
filming people i got footage of people
just filling up their trunks going on
another trip i'm like what'd you get you
know oh man you know i was i was out for
the ps4 but i got you know all i got was
this nintendo i'm like oh my god i'm
like all right you know it was it was
cool but then you know then everything
caught on fire and it was it was uh
one of those moments
you know one after one of those first
nights i was like
newborn baby just out of the hospital
off this culvert [ __ ]
um and
they're starting to get sleep in there
i'm i'm dozing off in some room you know
still trying to stay awake through all
this
and then my friend calls me what are you
doing where are you at i'm like i'm i'm
at my house he's like the fire is
jumping blocks dude it's it's it's on
your block you know it did get to your
block and i'm like what and
i look out the front window and it like
i said that familiar just sinking
feeling like
fight or flight
everything comes down to one pivotal
[ __ ] up moment that there's a feeling
i opened up the window and i took video
of it and i'm like
i look up at this flame
it's it's not it hasn't crossed my block
but it's right
behind the house
like whatever's in front of me
700 foot flame in the [ __ ] air
and i'm like
all right you know turn off the turn on
the lights
you know
get up
get up yeah
you know i'm not an expert on like 700
foot flames but i'm
or if we're safe or what the [ __ ] the
wind is gonna do like you know get up
babies crying i'm like
covid i thought that was it and now you
know there's george floyd [ __ ] babies
crying pack everything what what what
what what's the most important [ __ ] you
know growing up i thought i was like
grab the [ __ ] jewel like the jewelry
or electronics i was like get the
diapers get the [ __ ] baby baby yeah
and i was like i don't give a [ __ ] about
anything else and um
it was this huge
apartment complex that was being built
um
lower income i think i don't know if it
was good [ __ ] for the hood or the
community or whatever but it was
enormous
um it was a seven eight stories the
whole [ __ ] thing
you know my room my house was filling up
with smoke it was hot
man was filling up with smoke yeah no
the house right next to me was melted
and had to be uh
taken down holy [ __ ] melted yeah it was
it was over um and and um
yeah i i took footage of it we left
i came back to you know
called her dad or something like where
where were we gonna go at 4 am or 3 am
or whatever
and um
i come back and they stayed out there
i wanted to come back and like just
i just felt like i had to be there to
protect my house or just i just felt
like i got to be there you know and if
my house was doing good there i i i
had you know protesters and all my
homies they would come there for food or
if they got [ __ ] master whatever they
could be in my backyard with the hose
you know and i saw
every once in a while i just dip out all
i had to do was walk 50 feet out and i
was in the middle of protests and saw
the i saw the third uh precinct go down
it's on my ig profgompo uh
um so you can see that uh
and it was it's me footage the fireworks
going off across the third precinct i
don't know when in history of america
that the people have overwhelmed the uh
uh police department or the capital yeah
i mean capital yeah jesus christ it was
wild i don't think anything 1776.
i think it might miss 1776.
yeah
so crazy people were posting that like
uh
that
that photo of that iconic photo of this
huge thing on fire like you know before
it fell down and like hell yeah and i'm
like oh that feels different for me
they're like let's go and i was like
oh
i had to leave that that scared me you
know but your house you made it i went
back the next day and there was live
coals all over my yard still burning
like on my yard furniture and i'm like
oh wow
so i you know your house made it but the
one next to you melted like that do you
understand how lucky you are actually
are to if it melts next to you you're
you're next it was hot you're next all
my neighbors were leaving at the same
time you know getting in the cars and
[ __ ]
it was wow man
yeah it was a wild summer man
i i've been living my life like slowly
progressing i'm like an underground
rapper and i've never taken a step back
and i'm like i was doing better and
better and i just thought that like if
you work hard that's how life is gonna
be
but man you know some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
could happen to you ten years from now
even if you're traveling
yeah exactly yeah it doesn't matter you
i mean who knows we might go through
another lockdown maybe this year maybe
10 years who know we don't know that's
why you got that's why you have to
[ __ ] do it for yourself you get one
shot at this [ __ ] thing here yeah
here you know and that's
you know i
just keep it with the your
people you love in person like
i i got some [ __ ] [ __ ] basically got
cancelled for some i don't want to get
in the weeds or whatever but
and i tried you know what i want to do
is be a better person and i desperately
want equality for everybody you know um
but things are so confusing and nuanced
and [ __ ] you know just like those riots
like there's people there for everything
so
you know under the guise of being woke
or not woke or mega or not like it's
it's really confusing all i know for
sure is like the people i see in real
life again i can't wait to tell them i
love them
and uh just trying to have shared
experiences in real life again i think
the huge problem was like
covert really [ __ ] made people angry
and then [ __ ] yeah george floyd was
[ __ ] up and it was a perfect storm i
think we need some
play basketball with people who look
different from us and just share an
experience again
recognize some humanity a little bit
like
you know that's why i'm excited to get
back on the road because i really feel
like music comedy sports brings
everybody together
and and for a good cause if i'm rooting
the same team on or if i'm
at a prof show we all get love him
feeling good yeah it doesn't matter
in person you know none of it yes yeah
we're here for a common goal and and
that basically is to have fun and laugh
and enjoy ourselves yeah man
um have you ever played the armory in
minneapolis
i went there um
i when i did uh the house of comedy what
was it 2019. i went and saw uh wu-tang
we had the x-games in town i played the
x games you did
didn't want that one
two years ago they had like three in a
row so i don't know if it was
same one um well a buddy that uh was a
fan of the show was a engineer so he was
building all the ramps and [ __ ] he's
like come on so he gave me all the back
you know tour for that and then i went
and that night and saw wutang do uh
uh the show at the armory and i had
never been there before that was [ __ ]
great that's where i think that's where
the [ __ ] lakers played it's old oh
really
minnesota lakers played there
no [ __ ] and it was uh just closed for
like 40 years oh and just renovated it
and like put together i loved it oh okay
so that's recent then they did that okay
it's a dope spot
so now um you're getting back out on the
road too or what i'm going to yeah i'm
going to probably announce a tour soon
and i'll probably be touring
this winter a lot you know you just did
red rock
i've done that not just did it but i'm
going to do um
fiddlers
something some some big ass it's gonna
be with like the baby jack harlow and
like
[ __ ] like some radio show there um
that's coming up um
so yeah i've sold out shows and stuff
like yeah i've been really yo i have
i've been doing really good too this
year so you know all that horrible [ __ ]
has been it's been a [ __ ] roller
coaster yeah i mean i'm doing i'm like i
got i got like 26 aaa batteries in my
drawer i'm doing fine you know i got
like i got like kitchen shears and [ __ ]
you know what i mean like oh you're just
i'm doing it i grew up with very little
like yeah i remember when i went to get
a car the guy's like we got this the the
visor's like i go bro you're up selling
the wrong [ __ ] i didn't have air
condition all right like that is my he's
like well that's standard now i'm like
great then i'm good yeah i don't need
anything else i don't need cruise cause
i don't need all this [ __ ] i drive the
[ __ ] car yeah i'm the same way i'm
like i got fresh socks
so i was always embarrassed no no i
think if you have like 20 some aaa
batteries your
upper middle class yeah you're set yeah
i always had holes in my socks i still
do and i was embarrassed you know and i
would wear two pair
so it covered a hole but then it would
look like that one pair had a weak spot
in it you know what i mean but i didn't
care
and then now i just make sure it's one
thing i promised myself
when because i've been i've been i've
been on my own since 16 one thing i
promised myself when i got older as i
was always going to have [ __ ]
clean and fresh socks nothing feels good
like a good fresh pair of socks [ __ ]
with that really heavy dude really i'm
for real on that i wear the same [ __ ]
all over and over and over 90 hoodies
and sweatshirts and t-shirts but um
there's nothing like putting your feet
in a new part i once heard that foo
fighters had on their rider fresh socks
every show that's not just them bro i
would say 50 of all artists have like
fresh socks with fresh t-shirts i don't
have t-shirts but i love putting my feet
in fresh socks and then going on stage
it feels good
it feels good yeah i was number three uh
billboard charts
as an independent artist i just want to
let you know
let them all know man i i know i know i
know when it's hitting i know what i'm
doing well when next door i hear like
the production team laughing and [ __ ]
thanks guys um
so what's next for you you're going to
get out on the road do a little bit of
touring i'm going to [ __ ] destroy
dude there's a lot of things i can't say
but i am line the [ __ ] up good i'm for
you dude yeah let me ask you this how's
your mom like is is your
son your mom's first grandchild or to
your sister my sisters are older you
know what i mean so they got kids so
how's your mom love you having a son
like her only son has a son how's she
about that she's just she's [ __ ]
about that she's she's so good dude
she's
yeah she's the best with him and she's
still local and stuff to help you and
see the kids and all that stuff yeah
yeah
she's a teacher she's great she's she's
perfect yeah perfect
yeah and you said she remarried
what what was your do you consider him a
stepfather is he your mom's second
husband
[Music]
he's i love him
love you i love you mom how long have
you been with your mom a long time all
right he's so he's good to your mom he's
good to my mom that's all that matters
that's all that [ __ ] matters he's
good to your mom
thank you that that's a well put it is
all that matters yeah that this guy is
good to your mom you you already had
your dad he was and they're doing anyone
you don't know you don't need that
sometimes i hated him and [ __ ] i'll give
him a hug right now you know yeah
and dude what does your mom think of
your career like does she come see your
shows and [ __ ] uh every once in a while
you know you should bump your [ __ ] no no
i mean i have a huge variety of songs
right i have a lot of songs she doesn't
like you know what i mean i got some
[ __ ] i got some [ __ ] up [ __ ] but
then i got really really good i have a
extreme variety of songs look up flower
boy live
on on youtube and you'll watch me cry
like a little [ __ ] and it's super
emotional very good writing but then you
look up squad goals and i'm like guys
well you know i'm just like the one we
use you know so i'm like
when when someone comes up to me and
they're like oh i heard two songs of
yours i'm like all right who am i to you
then like what two songs have you heard
because i i cover a wide [ __ ] gambit
of [ __ ] like i don't think anybody has
range like i do to tell the truth in the
game and can you sing my father come see
your shows no i don't think that'd be
hilarious if he's been to every one of
them you don't even know it he's in the
back binoculars
um yeah
so what are your goals as a father i
want to know what your uh goals are
because you got a lot of [ __ ] to to
break you got to break that cycle
i'm not even worried about that normally
yeah i'm really
to tell the truth like satisfied with
who i am right now like yeah you know i
i greet people with respect and i like i
walk with confidence like i'm [ __ ]
um and i [ __ ] love my my little dude
and um i mean so far i've been there
from him it's been covered and [ __ ] i'm
gonna go on the road that's gonna suck
that's gonna be new
um
but
i know i'm gonna [ __ ] run laps around
my pops oh yeah you know what i mean
unless i develop some crazy late-stage
mental illness and start [ __ ] kicking
the [ __ ] out of them or whatever you
know but i got a dog for that you know
what i mean
edit that
you better add it down no no no no no
keep that down
that's like my number one joke my fans
know i'm i love my dog his name's pilot
we gotta we got a dog uh merch line out
all right
from the guy who didn't want to promote
[ __ ]
i got too much whatever ah
have it come up naturally i love it dude
um thanks hey i don't know if we're
wrapping this up i don't know what time
it is but i just want to say thanks for
having me man like please you're very
likable dude same i'm glad we connected
uh yeah i'm gonna be hitting you up
minneapolis we'll go out tonight let's
go out let me take you out in la tonight
um i want to get blackout drunk and like
just so you could think of me completely
different than you do now great i'm
going to ruin all the goodwill with you
that's fine we'll let everybody know
we'll put that on the ig story after you
know
um
just the way you smile man you gotta
anybody ever tell you look like uh look
you got a touch of like white damon
wayans in you a little bit when you
smile i've heard eric andre
um
it just hit me when you saw me look a
little i'm brad pitt
i get
all right i told you uh before we
recorded i ask everybody's uh
yeah we'll wrap up so we can go hang out
i ask everybody their first time here
advice they give i i never thought i
don't understand i didn't want you to to
your 16 year old self now after what we
talked about
because you said your dad burned the
house down at 15. this is a pivotal age
for you stop talking to him oh so at 16
what are you gonna tell that dude i'm
saying prof now is going back to 16 year
old prophet and saying yo i got some
[ __ ] advice for you what is that
what are you telling yourself at that
age this this isn't funny but it doesn't
have to be it's going to be worth it
it'll be worth it hang in there hanging
there buddy hey hang in there dog
you'll get there it'll be worth it
that's what we say all like
90 of this [ __ ] is hanging in there
sticking around staying in the [ __ ]
game it's worth it
dude thank you so much man this is
[ __ ] great hell yeah um all right now
since you didn't promote anything please
plug anything for anything you like no
oh man this has been great thank you
very much appreciate it this has been
great yeah uh as always ryan sickler.com
ryan sickle on all social media we'll
talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you